I think it's a continuation of the
problems that the conservatives have
faced look we've had we're going to have
three prime ministers in three months
we've had Rishi sunak was the chancellor
where we've seen low growth we've not
seen that growth in our economy he's
failed to deal with the inflation that
we've seen and families are really
worried about the cost of living that
they face and have heard nothing from
Rishi sunak in the well week or whatever
it's been that we've had the contest
about how he's going to actually tackle
the challenges that people are facing
today
does labor fear Rishi sunak in a general
election labor thinks that we should be
having a general election I think
everybody who I've spoken
spoke now the conservatives have
completely broken their promises broke
our economy and now they want to see a
general election they can't just keep
Doling out Prime Ministers every month
because they're in total chaos and
they've lost control of the market and
haven't got any ideas of how they're
going to tackle the cost of living that
people are facing is weeks more of
uncertainty and a potential yet another
change in prime minister through a
general election really what the country
needs well what we've seen played out is
a coronation here and not an actual
election where people have a mandate to
serve the British people of this country
you know Rishi sunap was rejected by his
own party membership only weeks ago the
people of this country now deserve us to
go to the electorate to put our policies
forward about how we're going to deal
with this cost of living crisis that the
conservatives have put upon the British
people and let them have a vote narishi
sunak is the first British Asian prime
minister the Tories have now delivered
two prime ministers from ethnic minority
backgrounds is it embarrassing that the
labor party has only ever been led by a
white man I think it's really important
actually and today to see our
politicians I've said this many times as
a working class girl with an accent from
Manchester for our politicians to
represent and for people to see
themselves within our senior politicians
so I absolutely welcome that Rishi
sunaka's you know become leader of the
conservatives party but what I want to
see is a general election so that people
can give that mandate to whoever is our
prime minister going forward and just
finally the markets obviously reacted
badly to the last prime minister and her
plans does it worry you as a trade
unionist as a member of the labor party
that the markets are so influential in
potentially turfing out the Prime
Minister well what happened when we had
the disastrous conservative budget mini
budget that was uncosted with tax cut
which were completely unsustainable that
was the challenge that we face and the
markets responded accordingly now we've
got a black hole in the finances
directly because of the conservatives
and people are paying for that through
their mortgages through higher interest
rates we need a fresh start for the
country where we're investing in the
British industry and we're investing in
people and bringing down the cost of
living and that's by growing our economy
wish you through that and this time as
Chancellor did not grow our economy
that's why we need a fresh start and we
need a general election